lo que vamos a intentar hacer en este
vídeo es obtener una apreciación gráfica
de los puntos de inflexión de los cuales
ya hemos hablado en algunos vídeos bien
lo primero que quiero recordarles es que
un punto de inflexión es un punto de
nuestra gráfica en donde nuestra
pendiente de la recta tangente cambia de
ser decreciente a creciente o
decreciente a decreciente así que por
aquí tengo la gráfica de una función
esta de aquí y déjame graficar la recta
tangente para algunos puntos cuando x es
igual a menos 2 así es como se ve la
recta tangente puedes ver su pendiente y
ahora mientras hacemos crecer a x puedes
ver que la pendiente es positiva pero
está decreciendo hasta que llegamos a
este punto de kim donde mi pendiente es
0 y después mi pendiente es negativa y
sigue decreciendo sigue decreciendo
hasta llegar a este punto de aquí donde
estamos cercanos a x igual a menos punto
9 y después de ese punto observa la
pendiente empieza a crecer
así que parece que algo interesante está
pasando aquí en esta x que se aproxima a
menos 0.9 parece que este es muy buen
indicador
digo lo estamos viendo de una manera
gráfica para nada es una prueba rigurosa
pero parece que aquí en esta x cercana a
menos 0.9 tenemos un punto de inflexión
así que déjame escribirlo este de aquí
es mi punto de inflexión déjame ponerle
nombre perfecto y deja que te muestre de
nuevo esto ya que lo tenemos etiquetado
para x igual a menos 2 observa tenemos
una pendiente positiva y ésta está
decreciendo decreciendo decreciendo
hasta llegar a 0 después de crecer sigue
decreciendo es negativa negativa y llega
a este punto y después de este punto
algo interesante está pasando ahora la
pendiente empieza a crecer
esta es una forma en la que puedes
encontrar un punto de inflexión
ahora también puedes encontrar puntos de
inflexión cuando observas a la primera
derivada recuerda un punto de inflexión
es un punto de nuestra gráfica en donde
nuestra pendiente de la recta tangente
va de un decrecimiento a un crecimiento
o viceversa y la derivada la voy a poner
aquí ok
déjame alejar un poco esta gráfica para
que veas todas las partes interesantes
ok
observa un poco aquí y ahora puedes ver
que esta gráfica de color rojo es la
derivada de mi gráfica de color azul
observan primero la derivada está
decreciendo decrece decrece decrece
decrece lo que significa que la
pendiente de mi recta tangente está
decreciendo y lo podemos ver aquí la
pendiente de la recta tangente también
está decreciendo hasta que llegamos a
este punto donde la pendiente de mi
recta tangente cero
justo aquí puedes ver que en mi gráfica
de rojo en la gráfica de la derivada
aquí tomamos el valor de 0 y después
pasamos a valores negativos en mi
gráfica de rojo estamos tomando valores
negativos pero seguimos decreciendo y
después de seguir decreciendo
decreciendo decreciente llegamos a este
punto que es nuestro punto interesante y
puedes ver que aquí llegamos a un punto
en mi gráfica de la derivada donde
cambiamos de de crecer a crecer así que
déjame ponerle nombre porque este punto
también es interesante observa aquí
viene algo importante una forma de
identificar un punto de inflexión en mi
primera derivada en gráfica de rojo es
buscar los puntos mínimos o máximos de
mi primera derivada porque allí se
muestra un punto en donde nuestra
derivada cambia de dirección en este
caso va a cambiarte de crecer a crecer o
ya sabemos al revés
en este caso nos está indicando que
tenemos aquí un punto de inflexión muy
bien ahora pensemos en la segunda
derivada y para eso la voy a traer por
aquí porque tengo la derivada de la
derivada y es más déjame alejar un poco
esta pantalla para que veas
completamente lo que está sucediendo ok
me gusta por aquí y ahora qué hay de
interesante por aquí bueno observa
parece que nuestra gráfica de la segunda
derivada está que tengo aquí cruza el
eje x cuando x es igual a menos 0.8 es
más déjame etiquetar esa información
aquí tenemos que la segunda derivada
cruza el eje x que es justo donde
tenemos el punto de inflexión y eso
tiene sentido porque nuestra segunda
derivada está pasando de negativa a
positiva observa lo que significa que
nuestra primera derivada está cambiando
de un decrecimiento a un crecimiento lo
que significa que la pendiente de mi
recta tangente
cambiando desde crecer a crecer y por lo
tanto aquí tenemos un punto de inflexión
y lo podemos ver una y otra y otra vez
aquí estamos decreciendo decreciendo
decreciendo decreciendo y en este punto
empezamos a crecer a crecer a crecer de
nuevo y bueno es importante mencionar
que la segunda derivada no debe
solamente tocar el eje x sino que debe
de tocarlo y cruzarlo porque podrías
decir que hay de este punto de aquí aquí
en el punto 20
es más déjame ponerlo en este punto de
aquí tocamos el eje x pero no lo
cruzamos así que nunca vamos de una
derivada que crecen a una derivada que
decrece así que lo importante de este
vídeo es que puedes encontrar los puntos
de inflexión viendo a la función o
viendo la gráfica de la derivada de la
función o viendo la gráfica de la
segunda derivada de la función
si quieres buscarlos viendo la gráfica
de la función original
tienes que buscar aquellos puntos donde
la pendiente de mi recta tangente pasa
de decrecer a crecer de decrecer a
crecer o bueno el otro caso es decrecer
a decrecer bien si quieres buscarlos
viendo la gráfica de la primera derivada
lo que tienes que buscar son aquellos
puntos donde tengamos un máximo un
mínimo y por último si quieres buscarlos
viendo la gráfica de la segunda derivada
entonces tienes que buscar aquellos
puntos donde cruzamos el eje x no
solamente donde tocamos el eje x sino
que lo tocamos y lo cruzamos hasta aquí
este vídeo nos vemos en el siguiente